[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel i'm
the host of the hangout
if this is your first hangout as i know
it is for wayne too
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
so as i mentioned the sessions are
recorded and shared to youtube as well
as our studio data science hangout site
so you can always go back and re-watch
or find helpful resources there too we
always want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's three ways that you can ask
questions during these so
you can jump in live and raise your hand
and zoom
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to put a little star next
to it if you want me to read the
question for you if maybe it's a little
loud where you are
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously too and
tyler will share that she was right
ahead of me and shared it just in the
chat
i just always like to reiterate we love
to hear from everybody no matter your
level of experience or area of work too
but today i am so happy to be joined by
my co-host wayne jones principal data
scientist at shell
and when typically we get these started
with just having you introduce yourself
a little bit and sharing a bit about the
work that you do
so my name's wayne jones um i'm a
principal data scientist in shell i've
been there now for 15 years
prior to that my my background has been
in um
ecological modelling so my phd was in
modelling the growth of fish
and following that i went to work for a
energy company edf
as a quantum analyst and then i want to
work as a pricing consultancy for about
five or six years then i've been at
shell
for
15 years now and
i would say most of the time i've been
the role of statistical consultant and i
have a very and as such you get exposed
to lots and lots of different broad
business problems across
all manner areas for some
people might find quite surprising given
i'm working for an energy company yeah
so you know i would say certainly in the
earlier years a lot of my time has been
spent developing open source software
for
for environmental monitoring
applications
yeah
awesome
yeah i think it it'd be helpful too to
for everyone to understand
a little bit more of what you do um
i love the example of how you're using
open source across
the industry and
would you be able to share a little bit
more about
the work that you're doing there yeah
sure i mean i was hoping to do it more
formally at some point in the future and
perhaps one of the meetups as well so i
can certainly give more details there
right but
um
groundwater monitoring
is something that
is very open and transparent industry
basically where we work with
environmental regulators
and we
periodically monitor our sites whether
it be petrol stations and it would be
refineries or terminals
and and we have
and we report out
the latest status um to the event to
management regulators and we work with
them to develop the best solutions
for
remediation if there are any issues
effectively right now this is something
that we work with a range of different
environmental engineering companies as
consultants and they perhaps go out and
do the sampling of the data do the send
the data to the lab to get concentration
results back
and then
in the past there was lots of different
ways of analyzing the same data so
there's an opportunity to standardize
make things even easier for everyone and
to increase
the level of interpretability from these
data sets right so this is this
basically
created
in collaboration with university glasgow
an application called gw esta
it's available as an r package
um which is just that and it stands for
groundwater spatial temporal data
analysis tool and you guys can just
download and and it's free to use
effectively yeah
and
and it's it's all to summarize what it
does effectively it's there to to to
identify
trends in groundwater solid
concentrations
thanks wayne i'll share that in the
chat window too
i just thought it's really important for
people to to understand about as well
because i think you've done an amazing
job
building the community around that too
um but i i'd love to ask you and maybe
kick off some of the questions with
what's something that you're most
excited about with regards to data
science in the next year or so
wow that's a good question actually um
i can't really say a lot a lot but i
mean i spay
i suppose the most exciting thing i've
done recently is i've been working on a
bid
with offshore wind right so the dutch
government for example
they have for each offshore wind site
they have different criteria
um for winning that bid effectively and
the one i was working on
um was on environmental and ecological
aspects
of
having a wind farm right you know how do
you avoid bird strike for example how do
you keep noise down how do you monitor
the environment how do you demonstrate
that you've had a net positive impact on
the environment as well right
and this kind of brought me back to
my ecological modeling
days
and it was really good i can't give full
details of the kind of stuff we're
proposing as part of the bid but i have
to say it's very very exciting
yeah and again will be done in a very if
successful in a bid it will be very open
and transparent so we'll be looking to
develop open source
solutions and also
you know being open with data
well while people are thinking of their
own questions i get the luxury of being
able to ask you the questions that i
want
so
i would love to hear a little bit about
how you've advocated for open source
across the company and
how you've kind of gotten people
comfortable with the idea of open source
well yeah that's a
another good question right um i would
say
i'll give you an example and that one
given i've been a sheriff a long time um
when we first started you
not only did we so let me roll it back a
little bit right so
when we first started using open source
tools we were actually challenged right
you know i remember speaking to an
architect michelle and him saying
don't bother investing in open source
tools wayne because they'll probably be
banned by shell in a couple of years
time right i mean and look at the how
the future's
you know panned out it couldn't be any
different right we use lots of open
source tools like art and python
in our jobs on a day-to-day basis now
i suppose you know what we're advocating
in terms of open source how i've
advocated it is by demonstrating the
success of having gws start all right
and
there's a will
our data scientists really like the idea
of being
making their code open source so quite a
few people come to me and ask for the
you know the pros and cons of doing it
right
now for could you the rest that the
business case has been open source is
fairly you know open and shut right you
know it's basically it's open
transparent you know environment
regulators haven't got a hell of a lot
of money they're not going to trust
black box solutions so it's you know
openly showcased but then but we're
expanding now and and
our business leaders and opening their
eyes to the benefits of being open
source where perhaps in the future we
didn't see the benefit that we have now
right so it's it's becoming a more open
culture
that's great thank you i see a lot of
questions coming in now both on slido
and and through the chat
joe i see you put a question into the
chat would you want to jump in
sure thanks took me a minute to unmute
no worries
yeah i'm curious um
when you talk about standardizing tools
who's responsible for doing that and
you know are there effect are there
examples out there of effectively
standardizing tools from monitoring
environmental impact
so
yeah so
first of all it's a global industry
right so we do this across the different
globes and there's different standards
in different areas of the globe right
a lot there are many many industry
bodies that advocate best practice in
these areas right and you'll see in the
list of generous debt references where
we are actually referencing best
guidance
get best guidance documents and this if
you like is a kind of document which
outlines statistical techniques
in a
digestible fashion to environmental
engineers yeah so
you know
it's those kind of best practices those
kind of industry bodies was helping the
standardization and
the level of um interpretation of this
this kind of dataset yeah
in other countries right it's not quite
as developed
all right and that's one of the things
i'm particularly proud of with julian
restart right you know is that because
it's open source there's no barriers to
its use and it gets used globally right
it gets used every you know i'm really
com
really surprised about where they get to
use so the last person who joined the
jurisdict group on linkedin he's from
yemen right we've got people from
you know all over the globe australia
america you know quite a well especially
america right but then you know you're
talking like malta china pakistan you
know it truly is a global tour so that's
one of the things i'm most proud about
amazing
um wayne random question for you do you
happen to have a blind right in front of
you that you could close because we
can't see
part of
if
sometimes
that works a bit better
does that work a bit better
a bit better yes there we go
okay perfect thank you
um
uh mubanga i see you also just put a
question to the chat if you want to jump
in
uh hi rachel and hi everybody thank you
so much rachel for the chance uh when i
just like to find out if your shiny app
is built using uh
golem the package uh
golem
do you know what i've never heard of
gollum if i'm honest here uh
maybe you can tell me a bit about it so
obviously i haven't heard about it it's
just not written using colon
i think golem uh
packages it's a similar paradigm to the
question that joe asked right about
standardization so it's a package that
allows you to develop uh shiny apps uh
using uh
a standard uh method that uh
essentially calling fe says
the the app the golem allows you to
build industrial
shiny uh apps that are robust and so he
has a certain methodology as you follow
in golem to build the shiny app so i was
just wondering if that's what was used
to build uh this
well
it isn't um and i will certainly check
out golden because it sounds very
interesting right um
it might not have been around when we
were doing this to be fair because it
was quite a while ago since we first
developed this version of generous that
um
i can see why column's been built right
because
you know
shiny is absolutely fantastic for the
smaller apps right but the large big
industrial apps
sometimes if you if you don't design it
properly it can become rather unwieldy
and very hard to support and maintain
right you know and that's really
important in spirit of open source
is to make it a way that someone can
come and run with it for themselves
right but you know if it's a big
cluster of different functions in in our
stu
and
and shiny which is not particularly well
designed and then doing that is very
very hard so
i will certainly check out gollum for
future showing the applications and
thanks for that
thanks veronica
i see there's a few anonymous questions
too on on slido wayne and one was
what have been some of the biggest
changes in open source data science in
your last 15 years with shell
yeah that's i mean that's a good first
of all i would say
it's been the adoption to begin with of
open source
um science open source tools
um
and if i roll it back even further
you know when we would do when i was in
university do a phd it was an
old-fashioned computer lab and we had
the old unix machines right and they
were thinking about 20 000 pounds each
and that's over
20 years ago now right and then you also
i wasn't about you had something called
s plus instead right and the license was
about 20 000 pounds a year and all the
rest of it right um so but within the
time that i had finished with finishing
my phd we'd moved to linux which meant
you could install on just using standard
pcs which obviously saved about you know
nineteen thousand pounds per pc and we
had started using now which saved all
the license costs for this plus more
so that's what that's going back that's
a long way and that saves a massive
department lots of money so we probably
could keep on more staff
as a consequence of that right and all
the benefits
coming back to shell now you know
i see you know changes from my
perspective is first of all
there was
a reluctance to adopt open source
software right so
you know talk discussions of those
architects but they just didn't trust it
from an architectural security
perspective right
and some of them fears could still be
warranted now right but there's also
about the
the technical correctness
of the underlying algorithms as well
right so i in the past i've done work in
r and we've had to double check it in
sas right
okay because the people that
traditionally did this didn't really
trust that it's still the new kid on the
block right but then
in my experience because i have such a
large user base then lots of the
functionality gets a hell of a lot of
testers right and you don't you know and
generally speaking especially for the
packages which have been used
at high volume it's very very
mathematically correct indeed i've seen
mistakes in some commercial offerings of
software because they're just not tested
to the same amount so then
there's the adoption of open source and
then there's the actually making open
source of you know stories like me where
you know we don't have this very
protective
business model right we realize that
there's benefits in doing open source
software do you lose that as a benefit
is one example of that as well so not
only are we
using open source tools we're giving
back to the open source community now as
well engaging the open source community
thank you elaine
another anonymous question that was
there was do you see new
types and categories of use cases where
machine learning or ai methods are
particularly useful in providing a
solution
like better predictions or
classification for example
some new new types of machine learning
and can you repeat i think yeah sorry it
was a little bit a long longer question
do you see
new types of use cases where machine
learning methods are particularly useful
in providing a solution
yeah
so
i mean
shell's business model is is completely
changing right you know there's an
energy transition and more and more and
more
i'm involved in
what we refer to as renewable energy
solutions problems right so this is
related to low carbon technologies
such as wind
solar
um carbon sequestration projects and
these are all fairly new right you know
and it's where and the scale
and the speed that which developments
are happening in this space are quite
quite surprising right so all the
machine learning technologies are being
used
to a lesser or greater degree right you
know we say we're using all manner of
technologies whether it be basic simple
time series forecasting
um
machine vision is also a strong one so
that's the deep learning lstms when it
comes to solar forecasting uh
look at all
when i first started in shell right i
was almost a heretic for bringing to the
table random forest right but then now
and now again why don't we you know
random forest and machine learning
algorithms such as that are becoming
part of the course as well another
another big use case that we have now as
opposed to our big ticket item is um
predictive maintenance all right this is
where we listen to the to the data
continuously streaming look out for
anomalies and warn people when we think
components are about to fail so you can
plan for failure around reacting to
failures when when they actually occur
so
the answer to your question is loads
right then i i mean i could you keep on
going for a very long long time right
there's loads of different new and novel
applications coming in
in need
and mostly associated with the
transition in the energy
thank you wayne there are a lot of
questions coming in about um
like using open source nutshell and and
how you are able to advocate for that
and so i want to say if other people are
experiencing this too and want to jump
in the conversation feel free to to jump
into and raise your hand
one of the questions was
you said your leaders are much more
supportive of open source because
they're recognizing the benefits
what benefits exactly are they most
vocal about
goodness right okay so i mean i guess it
has to do with the themes around machine
learning and ai right you know
in back in the day you know when
i was this consultant
um in shell we were rather a niche
um and there wasn't the general iet
support for us right so we typically did
skunk projects basically right and we
just had our own i.t infrastructure and
all the rest of it
um
but now
you know it's completely gone
you know
huge scale right and shell as business
and i'm sure lots of other businesses as
well
uh
we have the i.t departments basically
working with us now right supporting us
in our endeavors because they can see
the benefits of their base as well right
and i would say things like python and r
they understand
the benefits of deploying these open
source solutions for capabilities and
their machine learning and an
for example all right so and indeed
it's the chosen method to go if you
didn't have you know if you didn't go
open source there wouldn't be a hell of
a lot of choice out there
either for that
so it's it's it's really has been
revolution
i'm talking about the last 10 years i
would say not just recently
thanks wayne i i see joey you had a
follow-up question to this as well do
you want to jump in
yeah i guess uh thanks um
i already answered the first half of my
question but i guess i'll follow up more
specifically how do you get around
the the topic of lost revenue
to you know when we see so many
companies out there making
money off of proprietary methods
really a follow-up on the last question
what are the most persuasive arguments
that you've used or seen
to to advocate for the adoption of open
source
i i guess i'll i'll use again jesus rest
that as an example right
two reasons
right is
one
it's
transparent
right and we're we're not hiding
anything right because if you are
have
if you're a company selling your
software then you're not going to give
your ip away
by giving letting people see underneath
the hood right and the second one is
cost
right you know people so and in the case
you rest that working right the
environmental regulators
were saying this is open source we're
making it publicly available so that
other people can use it as well so
there's greater adoption greater
adoption means better
um
the more you trust it basically and the
fact it's open source there's nothing to
hide to demonstrate completely what's
underneath the hood it's all visible to
see so you build that trust
and also trees to use so there's no
barriers to such as you know like
environmental regulators
using it for themselves
so though
certainly in my scenario that's where we
see the
biggest benefits of having you know
using and distributing open source
software
in other areas it can be a bit of a grey
area right you know you have to and my
steer has always been you've got to make
that
business case bulletproof before you go
and open source your software right
because
one thing i would say about it is that
it is a one-way street right once you
made it open source you can't recover it
back so you better make damn sure when
you do make it open sources for the
right reasons and
and you know you've had clearance from
from the business to do you know
hope that answers the question joe
thanks for the questions too joe
um i see tim you had another question in
the chat you want to jump in
we can't hear you yet but i see that
you've unmuted
so i'll read the question and if you
want to
add more context feel free to jump in
but it was did you hit performance or
scale bottlenecks in the real-time
processing of sensor data for
maintenance projections and
if so how did you address them
yeah that's that's
a good question right now
if you look online you might see lots of
um
uh presentations about this from dan
gevin's our vp effect right
out there we have
millions of sensors you know pumping out
data points on
a second by second basis so there's a
huge volume
so we've actually partnered up with a
company called
c3.ai
and this is an industrial scale
highly distributable highly scalable way
of deploying
solutions analytical solutions to lots
and lots of data so it's obviously
cloud-based
spark-based technology
um at an industrial scale yeah so if
you're gonna have a look at c3.ai
this is
shell's chosen partner to develop these
solutions at scale and i think you can
deploy you know
uh
python based scripts and the clever part
is how you distribute and allocate them
jobs and coordinate and orchestrate them
jobs and you're using sparkly r to
interface with those uh not sparkly i
think most of the applications
is is python basically on c3
however
um we have i have done a work with
sparker i'm not sparkly right so
um
and there's a there's a
[Music]
there's a video out there somewhere of
us talking about panel analyzation now
it is quite a long while ago now right
so it was it was kind of novel at the
time
but this you know
technology's progressed and it's just
something people can do very very easily
now you know
and it was about paralyzing large large
jobs if i can find it i will share the
link yeah
i can try and find it on i'm in the
background too
but uh
wayne i i was curious about um gws that
and the success of it do you think it
has
a little bit to also do with the work
you went into branding it and like
communicating it out to others as well
yeah i mean that's
that's a good question why you know
you know
and i guess
i would say we haven't
heavily branded it we haven't branded it
with the shell logo or anything like
that okay
right yeah sorry that's not what i
mean just like
like gws that looks like something that
exists on its own you have a logo as
well and i'm just interested in
the process of
branding it
branding it well i suppose
it's not something we thought a great
deal about from honesty right you know
it's it's
it
certainly in the first versions of it it
looked pretty ugly sometimes as well
but it's it's its value is in the
functionality rather than the actual
image of of gws that i would say right
i'd say glasgow
university of glasgow have been the ones
who have been advocating
and getting me to sort of come up with a
more consistent brand identity for it as
well um
we could have even i mean it's grown
organically without much marketing or
branding for that matter right you know
so
more and more and more we're not
knocking on people's door
to to demonstrate the rest that you know
people knocking on our doors right and
it's kind of quite
but it's a very specific industry right
very specialist industry so
yeah and so it's a specialist tool for a
specialist industry but one of the
things we did talk about was
using that functionality making it more
generic
and perhaps using it in more in more
general purpose environmental things
it's geared up towards you know
hydrocarbon solutes within groundwater
you could use it for something else it
could be
you know plotting spatial temporal
distributions of
you know other chemicals in lots of
different places so
it so i'm not sure if i answered the
question there if i'm honestly right but
um
it's
so brand new this is just to summarize a
paraphrase right brand is something we
haven't thought a great deal about
marketing is something we could have
done more of but we're okay people are
coming to us to ask for it now um going
forward
um it's business as usual i think
i understood yeah i just i loved when i
was playing around with the the site
that it includes includes case studies
of other
teams that are using your work too which
i thought was pretty cool
yeah i mean yeah and i keep on finding
them right and i found another one the
other day
in fact we've all we've also just
released um
um
an article on on some of the most recent
case studies as well right so i'll put
the link up there for case studies but
um
i will see if i can find
uh
find the
article as well
awesome um i see libby asked a great
question um in the chat too and it was
when you were in undergrad or grad
school is this career path something you
could have imagined for yourself
no i never i never thought i'd be this
lucky to be honestly if i was honest
you know
um
i mean being able to spend most of my
time
in north wales
you know
have it in in a role
where you're given quite a lot of
autonomy you know and freedom to explore
the things which interest you
and i i never dreamt it would be so
so
and the work-life balance as well right
you know and i was thinking about this
in the day actually never in my wildest
dreams that i ever think i'd have it so
good
wonderful to hear
so
william
williams
sounds like he's a welsh speaker by the
sounds of it
are you there william
do we order for more level data science
i am
wrexham
i'm i'm in uh bell supoid which is about
20 miles the best of everyone else yeah
just go camping there a lot of land
roost
don't get off topic sorry
no worries
get in touch afterwards all right on the
linkedin or something
good job
when i saw that um joe had asked another
question as well around ai ethics
frameworks um what sorts of ai ethics
frameworks are applied at shell
and in open source data science in
general
you know what that's a that's a really
good question right and the way i would
describe it is work in progress at the
moment right
you know
at the moment i think the way it stands
now
it's important obviously but it's going
to be coming increasingly important as
ai gets more sophisticated right so i
think you know there's lots of people in
shell
working on building an ai ethics
framework right
i can't comment any further
other than to say it's work in progress
right but we we really do recognize that
you know there could be some this is
very very important especially when ai
is
is is more ubiquitous
right and
you know at the moment if some of our
algorithms go wrong right
if they're not
you know life-threatening right but that
could potentially change in the future
right so we need to be prepared for that
and understand what the risks are
yeah
i mean i remember when we were chatting
maybe this was a few months ago now but
you talked a bit about how
you collaborate with excel users too
um and i'd love to hear a little bit
more about that or best practices that
you have for people who
are working with all kinds of different
data people and and maybe they don't use
user python
yeah that's a good
that's a good question right i mean
because
when we designed gila restart you know
it was in in mind that
it's not a statistician it's not our
programmers that you're going to be
using it's environmental engineers right
and we wanted the barrier to of entry to
be as low as possible okay
so the primary use interface would you
rest that as it was designed in the
first instance is an excel add-in
effectively right where users have an
excel add-in menu
which behind the scenes
connects with our
grabs the data
um
sends it to our uses you let you rest
that package and uses shiny to give you
the graphical interface so
you know no one has that do any r
programming effectively
quick
what you see is what you get kind of
interface yeah however the code is
openly available and we do have bad pull
requests from environmental engineers
you know who wanted something updated in
the software rest of it so it works
it really does work in that respect
yeah
so good good question
there are a few hacks in the background
to make it work in excel right um
effectively how it works is
in excel
it takes the settings and the data and
puts it into a temporary
sets of csv files and temporary notepad
file and then it uses it looks at the
registry to see where our lives and then
it uses r in batch mode right so grab
them temporary files and run excel like
run uh shiny and actually dress that
package like so yeah so they don't but
that's that's how we
that's our little trick for getting it
to work in the background effect
i know that's something that has come up
quite a bit on like past calls or
meetups too so
how did you communicate with people how
to use this effectively
say that again sorry like like for
example thinking of the excel user who's
going to use it how did you communicate
with different stakeholders
how they should use the tool
yeah
well i think you know
the reason we used excel to begin with
is because they've all managed their
data in excel anyway right and and prior
to dress that you know they were doing
analysis typically in excel right you
know one of the
one of the benefits
in using just that is not the
sophisticated trend detection is
sometimes just simple plotting
functionality right you know building a
a three by three plot in excel might
take you all day right whereas you could
do it
in
chinese that interface you know in a
couple of clicks just with a couple of
clicks in the mouse
in our case you know excel was the
natural entry point okay because that's
where people used it right and in terms
of
in terms of how they used it we did it
with a combination that we have a user
manual right and we have webinars and um
whenever people ask for help we can we
can step in and
and give them introductions and all that
we are in the process of actually coming
up with some videos right university
class course student pizza there's a lot
he's creating some videos at the moment
as well
yeah
i would say
training is probably
our weakest point at the moment
obviously it's getting to the point
where we've got lots and lots of users
now and people are crying out trying for
training right now
we don't have the time i mean and this
is perhaps one of the bad things about
open source software right because
there's no
because we don't charge the license fee
we've only got
you know it's only our own time that's
going into this one you know
so
providing training is expensive time
consuming right and we don't get
you know there's no cost model there to
recover it effectively right so i'd say
maybe that so what we're trying to do is
come up with a basic set of training
videos that we can share and are open to
everyone you know
but you know yeah maybe that's one of
the negative things about being in
open source that it doesn't generate the
revenue to provide training for example
right
yeah
one point
i see libby asks another question um and
as a reminder if you want to ask
questions in the chat and put a little
star next to it i can read them out loud
too
but it was wayne can you think of one
big decision or choice that changed the
course of your career and data
whether that's education taking a chance
on a job deciding to leave a job or
something more personal yeah
i am
i've never really planned and
funnily enough i'm not particularly
ambitious right
especially when i was younger i just
used to
make decisions on a whim right
but
um i would say the biggest
career-changing move has been actually
moving to shell right you know and that
was actually my reasons for moving to
shell is that i wanted to move back to
north wales because i was seeing
uh a lady not for health right so it
wasn't even for the benefit of my career
from being totally honest here why i
joined shell right but it turns out um i
think it was the best choice i've made i
certainly like i like working here
that's got you know good work-life
balance really interesting
projects good colleagues so you know
and and it's scale as well right it's
very big so there's loads of opportunity
you're not micromanaged and you know
you're free to carve out the spaces that
you see fit you know that you're
interested into
that's great thanks wayne
um
thinking about your team at shell what
what does that look like the data team
is it
filled up into data scientists or data
engineers or what is your team like
that's a good that that's that's another
good question right um
uh whoo-hoo
so
we've changed quite a lot
right you know
so back a few years ago maybe phonies
five or six years ago we effectively had
a statistical consulting team right i
think about 15 20 people
and um
you know
now i would say
those 15 20 people are basically
embedded in other roles as senior
managers typically nowadays right so
you've got a whole range of different
teams i actually sit within data science
and within data science we have
optimization
we have statistical consulting we have
the data scientists themselves all right
and you've got other teams like machine
vision
artificial intel intelligence as well so
so it's just it it's gone really really
big now effectively it's very it's very
very big and i think the whole
organization is i think there's over 100
in data science data science only and
that's not including
you know machine vision artificial
intelligence so the whole thing's
exploded basically
yeah as for my role
you know
some it gets you you know
position in your career when you're
forced to make a choice between going
down the managerial route or the
technical route right
um
i was kind of up offered an opportunity
to manage you i don't know i don't want
that and it kind of crystallized me that
we want to go down the technical career
and
in shell i'm happy to say you know if
there's a very organized um career
structure with job ladders
and you know effectively you you in a
technical career path you could become
what's called the principal science
expert which i'm happy to say i was
awarded 2019
and that's kind of recognition
you're the senior technical leader and
your job you know if you go down that
route is basically to to be a technical
expert in technical leadership in this
field
i think that's a a great point wayne
when we talk around about data science
leadership it doesn't always mean
managing people
as well
so as the data science leader on a
technical
side what are some of the decisions that
you have to make
yeah just coming back to people right
it's not just because i'm going down a
technical career path doesn't mean that
i don't work or manage people but
i suppose the difference is
is you tend to instead of being a team
lead or a manager you tend to be more of
a mentor
right so this is bringing you and i do
this for the royal statistical society
as well you know mental and a few people
to get
chartered status and i get a lot out of
it right just just be purely nosy as
well i've been being totally honest into
different industries just to see what
it's like in other places but um
yeah i do like mentoring people and
trying to
shape their careers
and trying to get them on the right path
and use the benefit of my experience you
know to help them in their you know
i would say
the biggest thing is
you know
it was particularly in shell is you know
you have to use your initiative right
you know if you see white space put your
name on it
is i remember what someone said to me
yeah
use your initiative
but talking about you know i would say
from this is the team leads you know at
the moment
the biggest
challenge we're having in this space is
recruitment
all right you know and i think that but
this is this is a challenge not just in
data science
um
but also in lots of different areas and
never known such a jobs market to be so
um so lit one so liquid and never seen
known so many opportunities right you
know it is
it's definitely
you know a job
you know if you're looking for a job
i've never known it's so healthy you
know people
are spoilt for opportunity out there
basically yeah at the moment not just in
data science but in a whole range of
other industries as well yeah
so
so it's definitely a seller's market
guys that's all i'd say
i i love that you just brought up
mentorship there too and i'd love to
just dive deeper into that if you have
maybe some tips for
us all who who want to reach out and
help mentor people that
don't really know where to get started
like is it a formal do you have a formal
program at shelf or mentorship
yeah i mean
i mean
yes i mean it well
semi-formal send me informal i would say
right
what what i try and do is people who
identify themselves fairly early that
they want to go down a technical career
path i have basically help shape them
into
giving them advice as to what they need
to do to start achieving that right and
it's something that you know obviously
deep expertise doesn't come overnight it
takes a long time right
and you know we try and make sure that
people want to go down this career track
um
try and get the the right skills and
background as well you know working with
universities i think is a good one right
you know something i really like
doing is working with different academic
institutions i've got a good
relationship with university of glasgow
and one of the members of staff now
um
also got good relationship with
university of lancaster university of
newcastle uh ucl
as well right and that's part of one of
my job
is i'm trying to advocate
that we build more academic
relationships in the show right i think
you know the
current viruses
has paused that right and i think we
need to reinvigorate and restart that as
well and that's one of my roles was
senior
team technical leader to promote those
relationships
what skills do you tell technical
leaders to focus on
what are the people you're mentoring
yeah i mean it it very much depends on
the domain right so you know being a
principal science expert in shell
you know
you're talking about a very diverse set
of skills right typically got lots of
chemists as well geologists you know
data scientists you know so
it would um
what i tell people
if they want to go down the technical
career path is to just soak it all up
right the best you can tonight because
as you go
perhaps further into your career maybe
further up the food chain right you're
getting less time to do technical work
right you seem to get dragged in other
directions right so when you're early on
in your career
you know like doing a phd as well right
you have a lot of time to do technical
work so soak it up the kids you know and
use your initiative
you know
there's lots of training material
to do whatever you want to do up there
now right it's not like you know years
and years ago when you know everything
you can get books and stuff like that
right youtube and it'll tell you
four or five different four or five
different ways to explain the same
problem all right
i'll give you an example of using
initiative right you know
we bought some this is going back again
we bought some new pcs run some
algorithms realized they weren't running
any quicker right and it was like why
not well the reason is because even the
pc was quicker more powerful it's by
virtue of
it had more cores right but each core
was the same sort of processing power so
and some of the algorithms we were using
were
they were just single threaded just
multi-threaded but whereas you know we
wanted to move to a multi-threaded so i
use a look just on them on my own back
right
i looked into parallel processing and ah
and then when we actually
had some more use cases and i started
using this parallel processing right
that got me noticed with some of the
guys and then when spark came in i was
the person to do the pilot with sparka
for example and it ended up with me and
then now vp you know on a spot
conference explaining what we've done
there right so that's just one example
of using an initiative don't hold back
right don't wait just do it
like that i was writing that down using
your initiative
um santiago i see you put a question
into the chat do you want to jump in
sure here we go hey wayne i had a quick
question related to the
job market comments you mentioned
earlier
um
what skills do you look for when hiring
someone
and what aspects of the interview
process have you found to be most useful
to assess a candidate's qualifications
yeah this is
yeah i mean
in terms of you know
what i'd be looking for is good
technical depth right but also
you know if you're working in industry
as well you need to
you need to be able to explain and
communicate yourself as well right and
this is perhaps somewhere where the data
scientists could learn a bit more i
you know
know still go to conferences and see
really really bad badly presented
presentations are very very good pieces
of work right and i think in industry
you know a real benefit if you can
if you can be both technically good
right and also very good at
communicating these soft and complex
principles to non-mathematicians as well
yeah so
and often these skills are kind of
mutually exclusive or compete with one
another effectively it's hard to get a
combination of those two things together
affected
yeah
um
and as for the interview process right i
think some of my colleagues
advocate doing you know programming
tests or analytical tests beforehand
right you know some people actually
swear by them to be fair right but
um had that been the case i probably
wouldn't have got into shell i guess i'm
not very good at tests like that but
honestly right so i for that reason i'm
i'm not so uh
enamored with these tests you know i
think you just get to a good feel
on with a candidate you know when you
talk to him when you start talking about
technical stuff
you know you get an idea quite quickly
whether that that person knows what he
or she is talking about
thanks wayne
on on that idea or that topic of
communication i see toy and asks
any tips for enhancing those
communication and translation skills
yeah i mean i'm not the expert in
in that but there's a
there's a colleague uh in shell and she
has you know um compiled lots of
you know hints and tips about doing it
as well as courses you can take as well
i
um off the top of my head i can't quote
or think of any of them right but then
what helped me
is
mentors right for one thing and business
consulting right so one of the things
when i first joined which i was most
impressed about is it's people's ability
to communicate very well yeah
and for someone so you know
if you spot someone who you think is
really good at communicating right and
you're impressed by them you know just
buddy up right say look i like the way
you did that can you give me some hints
and tips as to how you do it right and
often there's a basic stuff as well like
you know the trouble is to take science
you kind of
focus
on a very
small area sometimes and you get kind of
obsessed
by the details right
and i think
i've done a
presentation about data story telling in
the past right and one of the first
things i had i i advocate is to step
back step back step back some more so
when you're presenting a problem you
give the bigger picture and you narrow
in to the data science technical details
rather than
rather than actually
you know obsessing about the details
right you've got to bring people with
you and the other hint i would say is
empathy
all right
if you think
more
empathically right
then that will go a long way so instead
of thinking about it from a date of
science
yourself in the in the customers or the
client shoes and think about it from
their perspective that really helps
right really helps
those are my two tips i love that
i think that's the way i should have
framed that earlier question around the
branding of the work that you do because
i think it's actually the empathy that
you put into all the work
that you do
yeah i think i you know i really do
think right if there's one tip i would
give to people you know is with more
empathy you make yourself a better
consultant
yeah just put yourself in the client's
shoes
definitely
steve i i really like the
um comment that you put into the chat
earlier too do you want to jump in
around being a tech person and
advocating for learning about everyone
else's role and just
repeating what what wayne's just said
and that you
you really need to learn
everybody else's language so this
can communicate on the same
level
yeah
for sure definitely
yeah do you find the question in there
too is
do you find that technical people are
overlooked and that people managers take
priority
i mean i can only speak for shell right
and and the answer to that is no right
you know i think
maybe in the past that was the case but
you know people are valued now for their
technical skills and not just their
managerial skills you know
it's you know deep technical expertise
has always been valued in show and will
continue to be so
thank you all for the great questions
too i just want to make sure that
there aren't certain things that i've
missed from the chat i'm just scrolling
through
and looking at the notes tyler is sent
over to me too
santiago do you want to share
um
a bit more about what you just put into
the chat
uh sure um
talking about
presentations and whatnot we use scrum
methodologies on our team
one of the ceremonies is every two weeks
where the sprint's over you review
something
um i've started to
[Music]
just to practice presenting in front of
people um just presenting something
anything 10 minutes five minutes just
trying to be succinct about it
uh try for some reason i still get
nervous when i present virtually which
doesn't make any sense to me because i'm
in my home i'm comfortable but just
seeing the little the cubes in front of
me makes me a little nervous
just getting those reps and i found to
be useful and there was a comment a
little further up in the chat that said
ask for feedback that's been valuable
because you can present something
terribly but unless somebody tells you
it's terrible you just don't know
yeah
apparently recording yourself is a good
one right to do
i've admitted but i hate watching myself
on video from what you know um but yeah
i'm going to bring in the whales angle
here right
and actually school when it comes to
nerves right a lot of people are nervous
in terms of um
presenting right and i think eventually
you know you you do get more confident
right as you do more so i think the
obviously kind of stuff to do to do more
as well right but from wales um
i think one of the scariest things you
have to do is go to this devil so this
is a national pageant and as a as a
child you have to do it you have no
choice right and you sit in the front of
the state on a stage in front of
you know
hundreds of people basically right and i
suppose
it's trial by fire right
you can cope with that they need to open
presenting another thing i really like
in um
school
is to get
young children to talk to the rest of
the class without being nervous is when
you bring something into the class
um that you really cared about right so
bring in something and then you know you
get a child
you know they're not thinking about
the fact that they're having to present
something to the rest of the class
they're just thinking about this
toy
or or dolly that they've bought and and
you know i think that can help overcome
some of the nerves
and that's one of the things i said in
the
in the data storytelling webinar
basically was that
i remembered my follow-up i was going to
ask you before about the communication
tips and you mentioned your colleague
who has some great tips
that they share
i was trying to google it and i realized
shell is a hard thing to google because
it's bringing up like linux shell
if you happen to have those tips or you
find them would you be able to share
them with us yeah definitely i'll see if
i can see that
awesome yeah it doesn't have to be right
now i can put it in like with the
recording too
i think that would be great
cool i'll see if i can dig them out
awesome one question i realized i missed
um and i know we're a little bit over do
you have a few more minutes one minute
okay great thank you
um
joe had asked he's on a train right now
but as we hear people talk about
potential for data science to solve
climate change from your perspective is
shell well positioned to push the needle
here
or are there coalitions
that can drive the data-driven social or
political changes we need
yeah so
that's that's a very good question right
and i think you know data science
and statistics and optimization
has lots of roles to play in that right
you know so for example
you know from the stats group has been
doing lots of work
in um
detection leak detection so this is
identifying leaks of say methane or co2
right so that obviously is there's a
direct benefit to the environment you
know stuff like gene vesta has an
embedded on the environment climate is
different we do not sweat the modeling
and we're moving to low carbon
technologies and we're bringing our data
science to bear on those low carbon
technologies such as wind for example
we're doing optimization around wind
another interesting thing is
is on microgrids for example this is the
combination of using battery you know
for storage got coupled up with say wind
or solar and stuff like that you can use
optimized
optimization algorithms
to reduce the co2 output as well all
right those are a very very small set of
examples
and you know
if you if you look at if you do search
on dan jevon's
shell you'll see you know a bigger
picture there as well he talks about it
in greater detail about what ai can be
today
and there might even be some videos
coming out soon actually
awesome thank you so much rain
we're just gonna put um into the chat
right now the
linkedin group that we all have if
if there's um certain topics that people
want to continue the conversation
and i try to put
a summary of a few tips on there every
week as well
but i just put it into the chat
but thank you so much wayne for
for sharing your experience with us and
all of your insights
really appreciate all the great
questions
uh too opportunity
yeah and i i know there's a lot that we
can learn from you
technically as well and i know we talked
about doing a meet up and showing the
shiny application and and diving into
that a bit deeper so would love to do
that as well
great
i look forward to it
awesome thank you all and
if we're looking ahead to next week
we'll be joined by lindsey clark
director of data science at healthcare
bluebook
as well we are
getting better about sharing the
upcoming
list here on the website too
but thank you all so much have a great
rest of the day
you